hey I want you to be loud and wrong
because that's what I'm getting ready to
be I'm so pleased to be here in New York
and as far as you cold but it's not your
fault so I'm going to try to warm you up
as well as to make you aware of some of
the really challenging issues when it
comes to understanding culture and its
importance its vibrancy is value in the
interventions for behavior change
Barbara has already shared with you I do
a lot of work related to sex and it cost
me to change my life in so many ways I
am the granddaughter of a Methodist
minister so this is the out of culture
out of gender out of school out of
everything for me to have taken on this
career and I often sit in founder why I
and doing what I'm doing but I really
think it's God's work and that I'm
supposed to be doing in all the
experiences that I had in something i'll
share with you this morning i think and
prepared me to look at an issue that our
society in our world is still very
phobic about and unfortunately use
nested itself an HIV and AIDS so a lot
of the examples that I will share with
you have to do with research that's
funded through AIDS but you know it's
hard to get money to study sex you can't
really get money to study sex itself
unless you go to private foundations and
even they want to be able to to mirror
what the federal government will will
fund and so that many of my studies are
age-related are STI related
I also look at the the contextual issues
around sexual functioning and and that's
brought me to kind of where I want to
begin with you so I do want to thank you
for inviting me this is an absolutely
beautiful auditorium I want to thank
Barbara because she's the one who wrote
who called and stayed on my team to get
a hold of me I was just here about two
and a half in three weeks ago so I've
been in New York three times since the
middle of January is unusual for me to
come as often but I new barber was not
going to hear if I tried to cheat an out
at the last minute Saul Here I am I want
to also thank my team Brendan Misha who
put together this presentation for me
and kept sitting me down so we
conceptualize it and I could get to din
what I needed to so I've done a lot of
thinking about this this is really a
privilege to me I seized the opportunity
to speak and to speak differently about
every topic if you've ever heard me I
try not to repeat myself I find that
very boring and the demonstration of a
boring speaker is a person who gives us
an talk every single time so I consider
this an intellectual challenge of my own
I know that I follow Cornell West's
legacy by having been a keynote speaker
i believe last year I'm often wondering
why there are no african-american female
intellectuals whenever we hear about
intellectuals we always drag out men so
I hope that maybe after this talk I'll
be considered probably not but you know
it would be nice if people would give
credit to african-american women for me
and not just being sexually I just want
a lot of people think I am and so they
think I do what I talk about and I have
a therapist and people come to me in my
private practice believe it or not I
actually have one and say well we came
to you because we know that you're good
amazing distortions of people but let's
start again and all of that issue to
cultural competence what is it that I'm
going to be talking to you about my dick
it's important that we define this term
congruence and compliments we're going
to be venting about both of them but
we're talking about congruence right now
that's the knowledge and use of cultural
beliefs and values from which
interventions are developed the
interchange is rooted in cultural
beliefs rather than the awareness or
avoidance of problems mmm congruence
requires a proactive approach to
behavior changed it comes from concepts
that are known accepted and then foster
group and not individual survival mmm if
that's not the antithesis of where we
have spent almost 30 years of billions
of dollars in aids prevention research
and mostly able change I don't know what
is because I can't name for you five
interventions that are culturally
congruent not by any name them they are
not funded by the government this is
simply something that Gordon to the
government does not exist but you can
imagine what a difficult time I've had
in my career finding the the flow of
cognitively based interventions that
you get this you don't think about
things you're not supposed to feel them
you're not supposed to have any belief
you simply are supposed to go along life
and everyone else does and then is
simply not the case when it comes to
African descended people we are unique
unto ourselves the history is a
significant I won't get into all of that
let me just get back to my talk and I
hope that there'll be a little time in
the end so you can ask me something ok
the language is safe we're talking about
speaking the language today there are
many many different languages but you
need to speak that's just have to do
with something that's not english ok if
sex behaviors contribute to disease
transmission and disease transmission is
the majority for the youth of the world
ok if diseases are transmitted sex is
usually the database a conference of
examination of all sexual experiences
should be studied regardless of whether
they were willful forced or coerced no
matter what age the person was involved
the general partner of the person or the
perpetrator the circumstances of the
events of the number of times that all
incidents occurred and so when I was
given a key award I want to give it I
was awarded it excuse me I had the right
of the grant nine times in four years
ago to get the first k on the first
minority to get a que in the world
that was in nineteen eighty isn't that
something I decided that I wanted to
study the sexual experience of
african-american women well two days i
was told number one you could set
african-american women alone because you
had to study african-american and white
women as the standard white women were
considered the standard in 1980 so i had
to do a comparative study and i was told
that if i did not include european
american women that i would not be
funded so what did I do I went home and
I talk to my family about it and they
said look girl you want to get somebody
you want to do the study want to do the
work walk through the door so i add
european-american to my study and i'm so
glad i did because it's so many ways i
was able to demonstrate the similarities
and the differences but what I did what
most people don't do is I control for
all the demographic characteristics of
these two groups so I wasn't talking
about middle-class white women and for
black women which is this way that most
studies are are constructed and so when
you talk about culture you're really
talking about a variety of things that
is all most important understood
impossible to understand but the second
thing that I did was to look at the
non-consensual as well as consensual
sexual experiences of men and i started
with women in the eggs and let me tell
you just one struggle daddy as most
people don't want to look and things
that happen to you that you didn't want
to happen but they were sexual they just
want to let me things that you wanted to
do but that's not studying sex that's
good time sex that sex on a date that a
good date but sex when you wanted to one
sex of anything that happens it have to
do with sex and so when I
when I included both was too quickly
discover that the non-consensual
experiences predicted what you did with
the consensual I can tell you girls who
will have sex and 10 on their own if i
look at the histories of their sexual
abuse before the age of 10 i can tell
you the girls that are going to get
pregnant in that unless it's early
adolescence environment in the history
of abuse and violence before they get
pregnant it is not rocket science all
you have to do is success the way it
happens bang kids and the things that
happen to you and the things that you
volunteer to do are all connected on a
continuum you cannot separate them out
and you don't separate them in research
you get a much and so when you talk to
someone and you say what age did you
first have sex first of all sex could be
touching the hand the breasts the penis
the problem the clitoris talking texting
messaging imagining dreaming that's all
sex so using that term means absolutely
nothing but this is the still the turn
and what age did you first have sex and
people will say who's 11 well do they
ask them well under what circumstances
did that event occur so I developed a
protocol call the wife sex history
questionnaire if you have interest in it
I have some cards you can write to me
will send it to you but what it does is
a structured interview that allows you
to collect data on the non-consensual as
well as sexual experiences that were
willful and we published all of these
things but when aids came along they
completely ignored the non-consent
peace I've been battling upstream lat a
little salmon trying to get this piece
in because it has everything to do with
zoos at risk when you look at gender and
culture gender and culture believes
sometimes endorse behaviors that seem
good in a western way we're talking
about Western we're talking about
anglo-saxon we're talking about the u.s.
we're talking about concepts and
everybody doesn't believe in so when I
think that when concepts are good in a
Western Way been really not necessarily
good for individuals who don't operate
of a Western mentality and I got into a
lot of trouble with this paper that
cited at the bottom way back in the 90s
a lot of feminists asked us to
contribute this piece of research and
I'm going to tell you about they want a
piece been demonstrated the strength of
african-american women and so we carve
out a little piece of data and sent into
methylation this is an acceptable this
doesn't sound feminist and I say well
that's too bad this is what we found and
I you know that i'm not i'm standing by
what we're doing essentially this is
what we found in a community sample when
i studied really proves all the groups
for control for demographic
characteristics greater sexual
risk-taking specifically non condom use
with primary partner that's the person
that they identify the person they have
sex with the most and that that is the
primary Gardner was reported by single
African American women with at least one
child they also were known more than one
teenis from Mexico because he worked
from Puerto Rico they weren't from El
Salvador they were from stick around
while you work for wasps they weren't
from although they were all this again
American women excuse me that's my apple
or
hair and European American women to
perceive make unavailability in to
engage in bardur sex and then finally
they were also elected to decide alone
not to negotiate or use condoms with it
hurts well what are we looking at the
composite of those three findings we're
talking about when who were not married
alone they have one child if you look
deeper they were poor they needed money
for sex is what we do every day isn't it
you take me out to get a steak on
volunteer sex with you firing sex did
you know that goes on for thousands of
years it's not sex work these some
people that wouldn't know men do it too
these are no harder sometimes a deal
right if there's an exchange here you do
this for me I do that for you you give
me a big diamond I'll have sex with you
tonight when marry women do it too but
we found an african-american women were
more likely to engage in what we call
this constellation of risky behaviors
and the thing that the other women that
I census articles who didn't like was
saved an accent partners about
negotiating about sex and make a
decision alone so they thought that was
a feminist attitude that's what I'm
calling a Western way but they decided
not to use condoms that's not good for
them so if you look into the
individualism as a model you'd say well
these women were strong and assertive
and they made decisions all by
themselves they didn't need to talk to
their partners but they were deciding
not to use condoms why would women black
women in particular decide not to use
commas make unavailability about 70
black men to a hundred black women in
the United States did you know that it's
that bad you don't get the partner
you're talking about
somebody you can hook up with if only
one and three african-american woman in
the talking services you're going to be
married owl to a black man we're talking
about a moving train but is wrecking of
people to be able to hook up in the way
that our religious affiliations and our
mothers and our fathers tell us and then
we wonder why women are seventy percent
of the race of new infections are among
black women why because the decisions
that they're making are at their own
risk in order to develop the
relationships they've been told that
they need here's another interesting
community-based participatory research
poses a threat to the gold standard
which is randomized clinical trials when
you do research that involves the
community it's assume if you have an
experimental group of the control group
now those you can do research here how
many of you do research who me if you
want to do the search how many of you
are tired of doing research but there's
two roofs at least that you have to have
or messed up when you go back but you
know what happens to that control them
they don't necessarily get anything
right after they have been controlled
there is no responsibility for
researchers to go back and to use a
weightless design in order to give them
the same intervention and in the
community based participatory research
and in the projects and in the
communities that we work with there
aren't any services that have to do with
HIV for women who have
sexual and physical violence and so that
having a control room and they would get
nothing so the ethical issue is to
require randomized clinical trials when
ethnic people are involved with
underrepresented people are involved to
have a weightless design so that they
can get the same services that can get
the same material after the study is
completed these are very critical issues
when it comes to community then no
longer want to participate they have a
lot of healthy paranoia when it comes to
research because they're not really
treated well and their issues and the
lack of resources are not really
respected let's talk about the language
of culture culture I'm really challenged
with touching the screen go back the
thing let's see here we go the language
the rules the values and beliefs passed
down from generation to generation
that's what culture is is the least
studied component for these groups who
are currently at risk for HIV and
they've I think that's odd because when
you do international research and I do
the first thing people want to know is
what language do the people speak so we
can make sure that we have a research
team that not only are by cultural but
they're bilingual but when it comes to
studying black people then we'll just do
moment speak English don't think of it
we're fine and if the investigator is
not african-american and let believe me
less than three percent of research is
conducted by african-american
investigators in alphabetic less than
three percent where is almost 98 or 99
percent of research includes
african-americans but when the
investigator the principal investigator
and decision-maker the one who gets the
money is not African Americans what
usually have happens they usually hire
some black staff right to try out into
the community and to do what focus
groups because that's where the culture
will emerge you ever hear group people
say on them
scuss culture today for you I'm going to
tell you what my culture believe it
people don't even know how to ask
questions to get at culture it doesn't
pop out you don't even know what their
culture is in African America do they
know they don't know because we have
been so brainwashed to think that during
slavery we lost it how can you lose your
culture excuse me how can you lose you
go it's like taking off all your clothes
and I know you're naked I always wanted
a verbal history that means that the
green are also brought over here it's
like it's all the story they told it in
the middle of the night they wrote it on
their hands their arms they told it in
their fables we have a history and the
culture and quite vibrant people don't
even know how to go forward and
acknowledge it so it is not a part of
the theories that we use it's not a part
of the measures so then nobody really
funded to do this kind of work that
closely concurrent research designs are
very hard to find as I said so when we
talk about these issues I'm not even
prepared to tell you just as a speaker
before me did I have all these measures
available all you need to do is email me
no I don't this work has to be done by
you some of you who are young and then
early in your careers and you're not
tired and you can get funding to do this
kind of work this is where we need it if
you want to make a contribution starting
cultural beliefs and attitudes give me a
hand
an amigo the language of ethnic mansion
this is really what galls people people
are afraid to acknowledge that in
matters if you speak to an
african-american if you are
african-american or not oh my goodness
why can't you have a little xenophobia
that means you think your group's kind
of better you know kind of used to your
rules and your values and everybody
else's hola can we have a little see the
phone you going out of here anything
matching means it people like to be seen
by the person who looks like in until
Paris take your children out of schools
within the only african-american a
minority check them out because if thats
google doesn't understand that you need
to see yourself not just in your peers
within the authority of the school but
they're off the track down here what you
learn if it doesn't have diversity take
them out of there that's not where they
need to be that's like putting them in
the middle of the desert and expecting
for them to dig to find the water how do
those two one of those teachers know
what to teach that one little child when
my two-year-old granddaughter came back
from daycare and she was rubbing her arm
if you heard me say this before and she
said too dark to jar it was my baby pick
her up and I said what are you saying
baby cuz it didn't make sense to me she
said two jars to jar Grammy I said who
said that to you baby she said the
children she said they rub off my brown
my brown the children thought that she
was just dirty then they hadn't had any
kind of introduction into diversity
honey I couldn't get myself out of that
car fast enough
to get back into that school say don't
you love not a day go by before you
bring these teachers to sit down and
talk to my daughter one who's gonna take
care of that business because she was
raised by me in my house we don't grow
up we don't grow children who only have
everything emerging in our household and
everybody goes to historically black
colleges you don't go on and grad you go
grab but you find out who you are so
nobody can take that away from you okay
and that's the problem everybody's
tiptoeing around ethnicity like there's
something wrong with it looking at it
since tearing race your skin color
doesn't tell you anything your negatives
of your hair doesn't tell you anything
the sides of your nose and lips
everybody wants today you're behind
everybody's pumping themselves up and
wearing padded Goethe millian to try to
get that look now that call it the JLo
lower than beyonce look if we've had
that look for thousands of years you
look at the be the top of top we look at
her behind she was victimized and abused
because she had an outstanding Darius
she also had outstanding labia and a lot
of people don't talk about the
sexualization of racism and the Indies
the fascination that people have with
the black body it's scary to me to think
that now they are circumcising african
men when they never even taught a lot of
wash and to pull down their foreskins
there now circumcising them and taking
the foreskins off these are adult men
because there's been one studies have
shown that HIV was less likely to be
transmitted and men who were circumcised
and lots of other studies have shown
there is no definitive difference in
there certainly isn't any definitive
difference when it comes to women and
their
raised and yeah now this is a whole
movement all over the world to
circumcise men and I question that
because the black penis is something but
a whole lot of people have been fixated
on for thousands of years and now what
we're doing is reducing it without
trying to clean and teach men how to
care for it and it concerns me concerns
me greatly that our ethnicity is being
torn apart by shreds and we don't stand
up people don't stand up and understand
its vibrancy well we were conducting a
research project in the 90s when Magic
Johnson disclosed that he was
hiv-positive so I thought is a perfect
time to add several questions that had
to do this was a study with three ethnic
groups 900 women who were representative
of african-american latina mexican
american and european american women
between the ages of 18 and 50 in los
angeles county so what we found was
single women reported more drug use for
four cents a greater fear of sex due to
STDs more sexual partners and a greater
change in these behaviors as a result of
Magic Johnson's disclosure comparison
married women you see that same
phenomena of single women doing very
risky things but once stopping and what
made him think twice and begin to change
the behavior it was magic Johnson who
was out there having sex with a bunch of
people looking single women saying I'm
infected trauma celebrity I'm a
basketball player and I have infected
that slammed people in the face if only
we had more people who had the courage
right to come forward and to let people
know that it's not celebrity isn't the
other thing to do with who you are does
it have it has something to do with the
transmission of the virus and the social
networking that goes on and to deny
then some of these issues really truly
belong there ethnic matching many the
difference and I say to you that unless
the studies that you're doing unless the
studies that your Pardo has the kind of
representation and decision making at
the very top level you shouldn't be a
part of the study that only hires
research assistants that look like the
population that you are dealing with I
won't do is sell you men without
appropriate full investigator who's the
man and I would prefer to be the
co-principal investigator not FBI
because I'm not either the man I don't
know what it's like to be a man I'm
married to one I'm raised one but i
don't know i don't have that experience
I don't know how people can tell me that
it doesn't make any difference as long
as you know how to do good research I
disagree with that I think the reason we
have fewer than three percent of ethnic
minorities who are some ditch do
research in and I ages because people
haven't had the opportunity and people
have them in righteously intimations
like I have to stand up in front of
groups and say what I'm saying to you
today now it's gonna be on you to do
something with it to challenge people
when you get pink sheets back you're not
actually pink anymore but that's the
response from the review committee or
you before your grants get review to
question the diversity on the groom and
once the expertise of those individuals
because none of those people are black
and lost don't know scared afraid and
want to be socially appropriate and
blending in the line and you will vote
against somebody just like
get local people cuz there's a certain
people all have enough experience scuze
me the other groups of 4 i'm confused by
themselves you know I was Harvard once
on the phone with Tony Brown me said
african-americans the only group who
still want to be accepted in love in
this nation other groups will simply let
you know they don't care anymore how
they are treated they simply get their
finances together and go buy whatever it
is they couldn't get in a ride in on
half then go get it financially so that
nobody can deny them but nobody's going
to affirm for you each and every one of
you have your firm for yourselves within
the context of your family it's not
going to come from this society and as
long as people are externally oriented
you're always going to be rejected if
you are brown and nappy headed and big
nosed and being whipped and big behind
well endowed and hanging low charge
encourages the word expanding about
incident today everyone wants to be
culturally competent I don't think I've
ever gotten more requests come speak
about cultural competence it should be
required for everyone how in the world
and people hire people today and not
certify their confidence to work with
different groups and that does not know
in the terms than they use it's the
history it's the skills it's the values
and understanding how people have been
discriminated against in terms of
disparities you don't know that you
don't have the questions to ask sexual
identity for african-americans is
extremely fluid why you too fluid
because of slavery my goodness we have
to do any and everything in order to
survive how can you look at people and
simply ask them are you heterosexual cuz
I'm not let me ask you about any of
anything else but we just going to talk
about him and her cuz I'm not gonna ask
you about same gender loving but this is
exactly what you find when you do groups
and when you do research with
we have a study is coming out though at
the bottom of this slide on
african-american and Latino men what we
found these were men were major be
positive to all the histories of sexual
abuse we found the beat these men have
different types of ways that they
identified them built and they did not
identify as gay that was not the word
they used and this is not a happy thing
so why I lived in the group stood I'm a
woman I would not sit in a group of men
lordy mercy I've got men doing groups
with women oh why it's just a quick way
of doing something that's inappropriate
okay I would not sit in a group why
would they want to tell me what they
need to say I mean to have my
investigators in a never what they said
was that being gay or blackmail latino
men and they were two different groups
we did not have them cuz latino mean
what they're all wrong and they all
spoke in their own language we're
talking about their feelings being
isolated rejected from Maryland
communities isolation they experienced
by being same gender loving and secondly
that this wasn't happy they had to leave
their churches they had to keep a secret
they had to bring went into Easter
dinner or Christmas dinner when they
weren't interested in those women many
of them had married and an attempt to
try to quote straighten themselves out
and do the quote right thing only to
find that that was not for them so
they're allow the body strong behind
them as a result of their not feeling
that they can make decisions about who
they were so when you talk about
identity and orientation it's not the
same we have some interventions that are
developed for men and women but they
never saw all these issues now how can
you do that it's amazing to me these are
all published materials I'm talking
about some stuff substance abuse
escalates when people are in recovery
because nobody talks
them about their sexuality and what it
is that they've been exposed to and what
it is they're actually doing on their
own so sometimes we make the issues
worse i overlooking the issues that we
should be talking about disparities
historical disparities in trauma I
developed a novel sexual health model
that includes three variables three
constructs one is body touching in
awareness this was a major issue that
has gender and spiritual and religious
overtones but many people have touched
to talk not to touch their bodies have
you ever heard of the story of open in
the Old Testament how many of your bird
read it if you haven't you gotta read
some of this the story of all the talks
about the Brotherhood's whose brother
passed away and he was responsible you
know in those days wives of brothers had
to be taken care of by your brother you
would inseminate that woman to keep the
line going right so it's brendan only
did not want to have sex with his
brother's wife so we fill his seat on
the ground and so this whole story came
about so that's the story is used to
discourage people from from stimulating
or pleasuring themselves I could use the
term masturbation but for so many people
that's not an acceptable term to use at
a university I don't know where Colombia
stands but again that just said oh but a
lot of people don't feel it's
appropriate to touch their bodies when I
asked african-american women about
touching their breasts and talking
touching between their legs I don't know
no I don't defend first of all that's
freaky and secondly my partner is
supposed to do that that's not for me
that's what my partner my body is from
my partner I get myself longing to my
partner okay so why are chimeric and
died women down your breast cancer than
european american moon in libra selfies
this is a deep significance it's not
just something where you can say people
don't know no they have cultural beliefs
that actually prohibit so what would we
do in our invention we teach women to
bring in their mothers their sisters
their partners anyone that they feel
appropriate can touch their breasts and
we will teach that person to do the
breast self-exam it's not important to
try to break them down on something
that's important to them into more that
somebody does the mapping of the lumps
and the bumps you know what I'm talking
about ladies so know what's there and if
anything is bigger or moved or something
new you know exactly what's going on
body touching is very more why is it
important HIV if you don't touch your
body you can't touch a piece hmm even
men I am identify Sunday who never crush
their own penises they get in the
bathroom stall and do this like you're
skinny and know how to aim okay but in
terms of touching and exploring and
pulling back up for skin mmm central
Amish is huge issue is it who is
supposed to be responsible for your body
taking care of it no one what it needs
and protecting it that is also been a
cultural belief that it was belief and
grew out of slavery you depend control
of your own sexuality this is an
important notion to have to read them
read while acknowledging its nice if you
have a part where you can give yourself
to that partner but that's not realistic
in the 21st century is it and then
finding interconnectedness this is the
one constant that kept us alive as a
people interconnected is the ability to
the
to somebody and to value their life and
the quality of it more than your own it
is a strong and powerful notion that is
reinforced by religion and by culture if
we didn't have interconnectedness we
would have passed away on the shores of
America that is you just till somebody
else wasn't even related to you and you
took them in and they were little in if
they were hungry and you care for them
that is a powerful tool in within our
community then some people don't even
use today because they see
african-americans is so deficient these
are the three concepts that we use
mediators and interventions and it's
very powerful experience to acknowledge
that these things can't be taken away
but they need to be adjusted and reframe
so that people could live the language
of emotional process and this is lying
and talk to you all day about but that
is it now we use the audio computer
assistant interview are you familiar
with you Cassie or we don't use the
audio at all you just use the computer
and have people respond to a survey on
computer that's the caddy computer
system interview nobody Charleston
people at all today hello my name is
Jean let me sit you down in front of the
computer some people have never talked
to a non-judgmental professional about
anything having to do sex their bodies
their sexuality the concerns that they
have I think that we can't become so be
personalized that we think that in order
to hurry through and get a whole lot of
people saying we can avoid that in the
connectedness as a professional
emotional processing about seeking in
the dialect of the language to someone
who can be empathic non-judgmental and
we can hear you in my studies we never
collect any kind of
data having to do with sexual coercion
abuse and violence or physical origin
without doing it face-to-face I don't
believe that that's an appropriate way
of collecting data so many of these
experiences have never been disclosed
before the settings are actually
conducted and I think the best way to do
it is to trained interviewers to be
empathic non-judgmental and to be able
to take down the information of all the
incidents that a person has now is that
easy to do absolutely not you can't rip
through a computerized interview with
that kind of format because we even have
to ask the interviewers themselves about
their own sexual and physical abuse
experience you can't train people to do
these interviews and in fact that they
can separate out their own life without
working within first this is very
difficult and I think one of the most
frustrating aspects of where we are with
almost 30 years of funding research in
HIV and AIDS and behavior change is that
we don't talk about mental health it's
not one of the danby's or the emmys
mental health issues are not even
included and I don't know a whole group
of people in the world that more need
mental health addressed an African
descended people I just don't I don't
understand how we can expect people to
change their behavior just because we
tell them to but when you talk to people
then you begin to see the level of fear
anger shame and all the other emotions
that are important to discuss but you
have to be able to do it in the right
kind of training format so that you it
gives data that's important to record
body language is something that people
know more about when it comes to looking
at African to sending people because the
body language is usually very very
telling isn't it you can tell when
somebody's getting ready to go off on
you can't use their icon
is direct they get way up in your face
don't it what's that call in the
community though you know about planes
dozens okay people don't know about the
does is essentially a TV show which is
interesting to me but if you know this
means that you can take a lot of verbal
abuse right when you play the dozens you
talk about somebody's mama you know down
say your mama wears combat boots well
you know I some easy simple one but you
have a quite elaborate if you get angry
if you back up like you're getting ready
to fight or you get hurt you've lost
okay the psychology of it is to be able
to toughen people out to be able to hear
insulting denigrating kinds of verbal
assaults on a person okay so Bobby
language is very clear top of my hands
on my hips and start our own like this
you know I'm getting ready to do
something it's not nice don't you
getting ready to go off so body language
is important but people don't know this
is the secret before we said some people
don't know how to do anything else I'm
thinking right up in somebody's they
they think that conversation well in Los
Angeles a kitchen jail for being
aggressive Thorin could you they don't
know about this will safe I thought I
was in the grocery store this is a
little aside about these kind of little
aside I was in the grocery store on
Valentine's Day getting my car that was
very late so everybody was in a panic I
understand that the lady behind me I'm
not kidding he was right here right here
next to me and so you know I was riding
my little check she was obviously able
to walk class and excuse me you're in my
face she's a whole you know I'm just
didn't hurry I don't really care get
away from me cuz he she wasn't going to
move she had a daughter she had her
little stuff already up on the bells
well since I'm Taryn I had a car my
space out here I've done that for her
she called manager on me I've seen by a
pin you know what I really wants to stay
honest and move away from me get away
how far you need to be so that it's my
turn my register this is my chair the
body language said liked about it you
dont have space because it's really
about me and you're not important or
it's about my anger and my inability to
control it but aggressive posturing has
to be it has to be replaced with
something else a lot of people are
frustrated and angry and they need to
learn how to step back and what that
means and I kids in school don't have
this kind of education people who've
been incarcerated don't have this kind
of education you have to relearn body
language it says a lot language of
funding reinforces the traditional
amount what we've been talking about
this morning reviewers don't yet his
information neither do principal
investigators as I've shared and the
congruence of cultural values is still
something that hasn't been researched so
this is our Center soon for culture
trauma middle of disparities 42 years
old we were funded by the national
institute of mental health and what
we're doing is buying behavioral
research trying to understand the
effects of trauma on the biological
functioning of men and women and
underrepresented populations in order to
be able to get better clear since why
people don't get the kind of mental
health services and while we don't
understand there will come a lot of
ethnic minorities are overdiagnosed
under-diagnosed not diagnose it all and
we really have to improve the kind of
track record that we have if you look
over to your fault right some of the
most exciting work has to do with al
static load are you familiar with it
studying stress of course all of them in
the distribution of hormones we posit
that African Americans like
knows other underrepresented groups I'm
going to have higher levels of stress
than any other roofs and then it's going
to contribute to their mental health and
summon contribute to the they're dying
faster earlier and having old bodies
inside while they may be young but
literally being burned out because of
the micro assaults then go on every day
that little lady standing next to me in
line and that in the Valentine's Day
Parade so so it was everybody was late
with their cards stress me out because
then I have to calm myself down to get
my cards written in their little um
blows and go and say Happy Valentine's
Day and what I really want to say do you
know what that lady did to me in line
and if you don't have somebody at home
that you can go home and talk to about
these micro cells they become macro
assaults don't they the next person who
comes up to you who might be too close
to you or just say something you go off
on and they didn't actually do anything
but it's because we don't sometimes have
that direct communication and get rid of
the stress that causes people then to
react in ways that other people don't
understand so language is an important
concept understanding what happened in
our culture understanding the human
effects of experiences understanding how
to measure each one understanding the
biological phenomena is just as
important as a behavior there is no
quick and dirty way to understand how to
change people's behavior then got to not
only want to they've got to understand
that what they have learned has a value
but it needs to be adjusted you can't
take it away you have to substitute
something forward because in certain
situations people will go back to it
when I go home for holidays or in the
evening I state that way when I'm here
with you now I'm doing
best to speak Standard English if I be
telling you just how tired I am but you
really think that I'm is incredible and
I'd like you to think ID and you know
that is just as grammatically and
syntactically correct as what I just
said to you now there is nothing wrong
speaking in dialect a just isn't valued
what we need to do is I ourselves
because if you don't nobody else will
and there's everybody in this room
everybody has an ethnicity what we need
to do is give other people permission to
be who they are and have the beliefs and
values that they think that grown up
with what we need to do is create an
environment where the differences can be
discussed but really we have more
similarities than difference what we
need to do is allow for the differences
to challenges so that we can incorporate
them into behavior change interventions
change the system and we know me do that
with a consensus and more of us that are
fighting this and me I think that you
can do that and I hope they should heard
me this man thank you very much
okay that was fantastic I'd be so happy
now I know some of you be home but we
best ask some really good questions
right about now what we'd like for you
to do is to come up to my cell phone
maybe a tie you can move it back yes and
so what we like to do is those of you
with questions and you're willing to
articulate in your preferred ethnic
mowed down before and ask some really
great questions so who gots the question
we have 13 minutes of questions so this
is really extraordinary okay I just have
a really brief question on your notion
of the 70 a frenetic 1170 again was any
african-american men to a hundred of all
that sort of presumes that the racial
concordance is the prerequisite for
finding immediately for Tessa vanish and
yes damn cig you ask people who they
prefer i have the most active american
women prefer after Mary been there are
errors an increase from four and
thirteen percent of couples in the
united states that are not matched as
easily so i think the trend is moving in
it has to move around in a very women or
they won't matter if marriage is
important you will just want a partner
it's maybe not so much an issue but if
you want a barn it with someone like you
what it means is if there's an imbalance
and the imbalance was not created simply
by chance it was created because of
incarceration of dirt death of men who
not interested in women and the finding
infant mortality contributes so we need
to raise rules in a different way you
don't because my mother raised me a
married
I did I wasn't bringing anybody else
alone that's all I was doing and that
makes our races to some people and on
television I taught my children isn't
very someone who looks like me that's my
dad not honoring me and my sun setting
by the year 2050 we're all going to be
brown I said but good 9 2015 baby
wondering about the fluidity of what's
more important to be partnered or to be
partnered with someone who you know
ethnically it depends on the person
doesn't it some people will say used to
be parted by someone who looks like me
some people who say love has no color
and I truly believe that I think
everyone has to decide for themselves
but what the person says I will not have
anything to do with somebody else then
we need to tell them what that means
because what it means is you're making a
decision that may affect your entire
life yes thank you that was pink all
right yes okay I really want to hear
your question so here yes I am um
everything that you did I just feel
deeply about through my own professional
experiences working in research on
specifically dealing with HIV and
provision in the southeast that
oftentimes targets the african-american
community specifically I feel fortunate
to be a part of that effort but one of
the things that I find challenging is
that the way that you talked about
people's experience and what their
cultural values are where
african-american women are concerned
they're making certain decisions that
are cleaner that risk because of their
socioeconomic
or your community or what have you
living in a rural community committed
partner and selection and so on and so
forth but one of the things that I
thought that was really empowering that
I tried to do myself is not saying what
you're doing it's wrong button to try to
come up with some strategies on how they
if they feel like that something that
they still want to continue to do how
they can do it better how they end was
safer yes what are some of the things
that your recommended to women on this
trip well you know you raised a very
good question because a lot of people
don't have options you know they really
do have to stay in the situation that
they are in for instance I work with a
lot of sex workers I think that's a
great example of a roof and you probably
want to say oh stop that you know come
on over there I've worked with call
girls and sex workers in Las Vegas and
in California abuse women who are
wealthier than I'll ever be so you know
the most I'll do want to do it right but
very well and what's the most isn't
what's the motivation to change it's not
because they realize there is a no more
about Molly tonight and they have taught
me how to teach people about body they
know so much about the body so where do
I go with that I'm go back what were you
supposed to do with your back babe I
truly believe in the reasons and the
rapes or so high while some groups
because they have no context just
looking at condom use it was cool
recommended that when we would want some
more particle
organiz they know that and birth control
pills you don't understand that the
reason something wrong use these things
is because they saw in their lifetimes
people using them who not blood clots in
an example of birth control pill or
norplant who couldn't get those things
out of their arms away went way up with
your shoulders and their mergers made
you certain they don't understand the
trauma that has come from being a room
two people felt that they can exploit so
you have to ask questions about how has
your family been treated in a bit we do
research in places that would allow
black people don't school clothing funk
in mine and UCLA's another I'm not just
picking on who's been to this clinic
ever been here not been able to be
served you've got to give a history what
do you know about jumping what did God
intend for you to do why are you here
was it to make money by using your body
most woman women that I talked to a
center of snow I really wanted to be a
teacher have got my hook my hope what
stopped you I had to make money got
pregnant without well well what was that
all about well almost stepfather was
abusive nikka a second hook you see if
you take the time to do the qualitative
work you're going to find a way to bring
those people out do you think that this
is the way you want to end your life
what do you want your children to know
about because most of these women but
we're so wealthy do their children Bobby
Moore businesswoman of well they were
but you see they didn't know what the
business was just worried what are you
children
say about you when they find out does it
go find out you can get people you gotta
come at it another way than just saying
well you're gonna die hey I can't I
going home in LA right from the airport
to miles and sky because that's the
stabilities so you have to know people
how to you have to have a clinical
background you have to train in that
area to know how i can sell used cars
because I know how not because I want to
be manipulative but you've got to be
able to get to people's hearts see HIV
is all cognitive isn't it if you know
there's a risk you'll change your
behavior not if I can have somebody in
my Mary home and I've never had anybody
know if anybody can say hey thank you
and say it to me in a way that I've
never heard before hey I'm gonna die
anyway and when i hear from couples we
have a study in cerebral score two
couples and one of sizes here in
Columbia yahoo is lands over gene win
good rowdy Clemente others in
Philadelphia with the gym acts is that
the negative partners and escorting
couples that for once positive one is
negative the pot negative one will say
hey i love this person i'm dying will
die together that's true love so you
have to understand emotions history what
their legacy is what they want how many
want to be remembered where is this in
an intervention okay so shall we go to
you sir thank you thank you dr. Wallace
who your question why secret thing yes
thank you for your important inside I'm
a clinician and I was fortunate enough
to be born and grew up in Allah and not
too far from reason of this tree little
bit brothers often and it's the first
time that I've heard about it does
when I grew up he does it all the time
soon so forth and when I learned to be a
clinician it was clear that this was
something that had come out of Vienna
with upper class folks we sit in
Eagleton and my first patient were truck
drivers and stuff they look at me but up
until I started talking English and then
the kids I discovered that the kid is
know how to play the dozens and that was
part of the problem so we had to
practice it does you played it cyclic
love and psychotherapy okay and i did a
poker how you played it does one of the
ways in which you create certain kinds
of kids were designated hyperactive that
hyperactivity some of them don't know it
doesn't but thank you so much because
you know this can be done canton this is
not rocket science we simply have to
move out of our comfort low and out of
the Western Way yes thank you yes ma'am
my question for you is what we do as
educators those who are not going to a
doing research or what we teachers in
the classroom yes a possibly future
administrative what we do concerning
these each because I think I issues you
staying in your research you start
seeing you know the girls who are
sexually active and I teach middle
school folks from some of them removes
in the conversations they have in the
classroom sometimes itself you things
what can we as role models especially
those of us who work at one time a
teenager or at the American female
what can review as possible role models
and educators with that such a great
question thank you for variety my
parents were teachers and I actually
learned quite a bit from the back of the
classroom because after my class is over
I go and sit in their classes until
we're ready to go home and what I saw
them doing was to involve the entire
class and whatever educational
experience needed to go on so if there
was a little side conversation about sex
or some you know anything that it had to
be in part of the group and then what
they did was create a whole group in
that class those kids have an
affiliation and a title one another that
then span beyond just the fact that they
were sitting together they all had to
achieve that collective existed and that
dinner connectedness there was named
body we just made a name it was a whole
class with making a new somebody who's
fooling around you SAT him down as you
say hey our class can't listen we can't
learn if you sit sir come on you know be
a part of us don't stand out don't act
out and the second thing that I saw him
do is involve all of the teachers the
creative community that have the same
idea of sand concept it wasn't one
teacher you can't do about yourself you
see teachers being given Awards in the
United States I don't know there were
other people there involved in their
success with kids because you can't just
do it yourself you'll be worn out won't
you with one clan to be worn down this
today and I work with schools the
teachers are raising them they've got
extra clothes and then bring clothes
they've got clinics and got washcloth or
the children or dirty meat I mean it's
just amazing thank you love coffee
because children are working all that to
support their families to come to school
what children are gone through today is
just unspeakable but you can't change in
so when bringing the entire teacher body
and the principles to support the
efforts of these teachers some other
teachers need to know they're studying
the singing frustrations and it isn't
just a Man Thing Thing sometimes for
some kids other individuals who aren't
matching the group's can make serve left
levels and certain lessons more real for
them so what I suggest you do is to get
together with a group of teachers and go
to your principal and say we want
diversity we want and think immersion in
a different way and we think that we
want to bring in information into our
classroom into our school so the kids
really do understand they have options
they have choices and the proud they are
of themselves the less lighting they are
to act out sexually drug wise criminal
wise right is this is not rocket science
and they can achieve does that help you
this side is is failing me I need
someone in know my business Oh we'd be
what you're going to get your question
quickly because I put a little bit of
cushion in the program every book of
Renato from your elbow out and i'll make
my entry shorter I want to hear from
everyone who wants to talk to me please
Oh regarding sexual behavior yes and
holistic health counselors we look at my
body
syren so when we're talking to our
clients and we're looking at their
behavior as far as what they're eating
Ramadi is driven by emotional eating yes
and some of them do have some issues
such as sexual abuse and math a lot of
it may be related to sex so they made
food and i was wondering in your
research have you ever touched on that
piece of it they remove the nutritional
component because although they may not
be dying directly from an STD or they
could be killing themselves because of
their poor nutritional choice is dying
from heart disease and I think we know
yet so I just wanted one done research
in that area and if not we also found as
a natural choice of like chocolate as a
team of people who may be interested in
doing that yes I'll go about heart well
I have cars so I'm going to bring it
down when I'm I'll finish you know I
have not done the research what i have
done is to ask I can marry women about
their bodies Latinos about their bodies
and it definitely has a connection to
the early sexualisation that we put on
some very room you know girls who are
what I call oversized before they get
into puberty that they look like they
have breast development and don't
they're just chubby and you know chubby
goes on your breasts are just bad right
we all know that it's just back to you
so they look like they're developing and
they're approached by the rest of the
community and the world is little
precocious girls they're hit on and in
order to discourage them this is what
comes and rear man Barry all look in the
50 black range and is a absolute classic
if you want to read about this they
talked about it of black girls over
eating in order to make themselves
actually less attractive so that they
would not be sexual
too early and then of course once you
get that history and you don't have a
good exercise regimen and you don't have
a limit that fat stays with you until
you go on from puberty into the rest of
sometimes your adulthood as an
overweight person so it is definitely
important thing to look at because body
image is part of that body awareness
concept that it wasn't on this screen
but it is part of it and people being
aware underneath fictions and above your
knees black women Latino women send more
women are more money on their hair their
makeup their fingernails and their shoes
isn't that amazing and not all you
anything that has anything to do with
the trunk okay like that's like a no-fly
zone so we absolutely have to help
people to identify who do you want to be
this may not be how you look now why do
you want to look and that that's the
standards have to be ethnic right and we
actually asked them out there that have
that are well proportioned so they don't
have to be real thin like they used to
be very important topic and you should
be studying it
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu